the Mobile World Congress is open
thousands of people are in Barcelona
Spain to see new smartphones gadgets and
services for the mobile market google
today announced a new way to deliver
wireless access to places with little or
no connectivity it's called the project
Titan Bloomberg senior vice Prost senior
vice president of mobile presented the
project these are floating cell towers
but instead of balloons we use a very
lightweight solar powered airplanes
flying in the sky and so you can imagine
a constellation of balloons and planes
together which we can stitch together to
create this mesh of floating cell towers
that's what we are trying to do and it
makes a lot of sense because these
planes can supplement areas where we
need extra capacity think of a disaster
relief zone you need temporarily high
connectivity there and we can just fly
these planes over the dough say yes as
well so just like we tested with loon
about two years ago project Titan is
about to take its first first major step
which is will be flying these planes out
in the coming few months now that wasn't
all that google announced in the coming
months the internet search giant will
create its own mobile virtual network
operator potentially competing with AT&T
and Verizon but don't expect to sign up
with google just quite yet Google's
senior vice president spoke with
bloomberg businessweek's brad stone at
mobile world we don't intend to be a
network operator at scale you know
carrier partners are the ones who
provide services and even the effort we
do here we are actually working with
carrier partners but you'll see as you
know announced it in the coming months
but our goal here is to you know drive a
set of innovations which we think the
ecosystem should adopt and hopefully you
know we will get traction we again do it
at a small enough scale so that just
like Nexus devices people see what we
are doing and hopefully carry your
partners if they think ideas are good
they can adopt them but that's what this
project is about and I do so wonder
though if some your carrier partners you
maybe you're bigger ones like a verizon
natt might look
this and and wonder whether Google you
know one of their big partners on
Android is also becoming in some way
maybe a small way but in some
significant way a competitor you know
it's for me we have better years of fact
I part of running Android and how we do
it and you know we keep getting asked
these questions but you know we've
talked with them about all this you know
in fact we're actually working with some
of these carrier partners to do what
we're doing